so now I'd like to refer to prevent our
speaker today professor bill Burnett
so bill is an adjunct professor of
mechanical engineering and the executive
director of the design program at
Stanford he directs the undergraduate
and graduate program in the design and
teaches at the d.school he received his
Bachelors of Science and Masters of
Science in product design at Stanford
and has worked in startups and fortune
500 companies including seven years at
Apple designing award-winning laptops
and a number of years in the toy
industry designing Star Wars action
figures
he holds a number of mechanical and
design patents and design awards and in
addition to his duties at Stanford he's
on the board of vas a socially
responsible fashion startup and advises
several other startup companies so with
that bill I'd like to turn it over to
you thank you very much we'll just get
started here and that we try to create a
little bit of a provocative title meet
buying an empty why your customers can't
tell you what they want and from the
looks of it I'm for participants we have
here I guess but that'll work but it's
really an interesting it's an
interesting conversation and I have this
conversation a lot with people when they
either are reading about design thinking
or they've maybe been to one of our
workshops the master class which is
coming up in June or one of the other
workshops we do and they go oh wait a
minute do this Design Thinking thing
this it's kind of it's it's kind of
pretty simple isn't it you just go out
and ask customers what they want and
then you build it and then they say
that's it and then you're done right and
it really doesn't work that way so to
stick a little bit of a step back just
make sure everybody's on the same page
Design Thinking is both a process and
what we call a set of mindsets the way a
way of thinking or a culture that you're
creating your organization's and this is
the pretty common diagram you see this
all over the d.school website and I
website and bank for them this notion
that it's a kind of a five step process
you start with empathy you're you define
or redefine the problem IBA poisonings
have lots and lots of ideas and then you
prototype and test
the thing about this diagram that's a
little bit misleading is it looks like
there's a pretty woman the process but
in fact it's not bad at all
what happens is people enter design
teams enter this process at various
points maybe they have an idea already
that they want to try with customers
maybe they don't even know what their
what their customers who their customers
are going to be if they're a brand-new
startup but this is sort of the way we
describe it and the way I've always
talked about these kinds of process
diagrams just remember the diagram isn't
the process it's just a way of breaking
it down so we can teach it I like to use
an analogy to golf if I were going to
try to cheat shoot a lot we can try to
learn to play golf I couldn't teach
anyone because I'm a terrible golfer but
I was gonna learn to play golf the
teacher would probably break the golf I
swing down into a number of things like
how do I hold the club what's the proper
grip how do you address the ball how do
you place the ball on a tee how do you
bring the club back so each of these
pieces would be described as a separate
step but of course that's not what a
golf swing is a golf swing is a
continuous you know a beautiful
continuous motion and results in the
golf ball going where you want it to go
so remember that the process diagram is
not the way the process actually unfolds
when we do it that's one of the reasons
we like to talk about the mindsets of
design thinking the way in which you
know designers think and the way in
which if you have a culture of
creativity your design team or your
company would think I always say you
start with curiosity you know we're
trained as engineers designers people
you know if you're marketing finance
whatever the discipline you are in an
organization they're trained to think
about the world sort of with a skeptical
skeptical rationalism you break problems
down into you know smaller and smaller
steps to rationalize them you use your
logic and your deductive reasoning to
make decisions that's not a particularly
useful way to think about doing
innovation because when you're doing
innovation you're moving into a future
where nothing exists yet where the
things
you're trying to invent haven't been
invented and so there really isn't much
to be skeptical rational about it's much
more interesting and much more
generative to be curious so we start
with curiosity and we typically reframe
the problem that blocks called define I
always called redefine because the
typically we've been given the wrong
problem to solve a lot of problems are
sort of you know out there in the world
but the real problem is something kind
of either a deeper or a more abstract
level we like radical collaboration
crossing multiple teams we'd like to be
mindful of our process because when
you're in the middle of a converging
crowd the process we're trying to bring
things together it's important to know
that's not a good time for brainstorming
when you're in a divergent part of the
process they're looking for lots more
ideas that's when you want to reach out
collaborate and brainstorm Lawyer and
then of course we have a bias to action
because of this sort of problem we're
going to talk about next about why
people can't tell you what they want
since there's not a lot of data to be
analyzed and there's not much that we
can plan with we just like to start by
doing so with that sort of a background
you know we always say you know with
design thinking we always said that we
start with the people not the problem
I've been a consultant for you know 25
30 years you know because someone might
come in and say hey you know we're a
company and we make this these certain
products and we'd like to make new in a
new more innovative versions of these
products and that's typically the wrong
place to start we go back out and say
well that's interesting let's just start
with who your users are who your
customers are and go there because most
problems are actually solutions
masquerading as a problem this the new
weald project is the classic example
who's doing a project for a company that
makes wheel barrels actually it's
slightly disguised project they made
another really really common industrial
product that you'll find on every job
site we're going to say they made wheel
girls and they wanted us to do
innovative wheel barrow and so the
problem of course with that framing of
the problem is that the priority is
described as a solution they want
another wheel go they just want an
innovative one that might result in some
you know small product modifications you
know two wheels instead of one better
handles more ergonomic you know design
of the lifting process so the people
don't hurt themselves but at the end of
the day you're still going to end up
with a slightly modified wheel barrel
and so that's an example where the
solution is not actually what you're but
the problem is the problem that a wheel
barrel solves if you step back a second
is that you know there's workers all
over a jobsite and materials are
typically delivered to the jobsite and
around the periphery because it's easier
for trucks to drop things off in pallets
full of let's say bricks you know it can
perforate the jobsite and therefore you
can't get the bricklayers are over
somewhere else and so they come with
their wheelbarrows daytime mode if you
bricks into a wheelbarrow and they
buckle each other where they are
enjoying the work so the problem isn't
wheel grows the problem is the
dislocation of workers and supplies once
you frame the problem that way there's
lots and lots of ways you can solve it
that are much more innovative than
simply thinking about a new wheelbarrow
to give you one example you could
instead of delivering all the bricks on
pallets to the edge of the jobsite you
could have Amazon deliver Direction
individual or small quantities with dirt
with their army of drones in which case
locating each of the bricklayers by the
cellphone coordinates in their pocket
their GPS receivers in their cell phones
would simply transmit their location on
site and the drone would put the bricks
exactly where they wanted them you would
never come to a solution like I don't
understand that's a a good solution but
you never come to a solution that had
that much innovation in it if you were
just brainstorming wheelbarrows so this
whole notion that you just pick a group
of users and ask them what they want
what they need it just doesn't work and
here's here's the here's 30 s and why
this is the famous Henry Ford quote
right that he said if I'd asked people
what they wanted they would have said
faster horses that's just as a
disclaimer here I want to point out that
it's most likely that Henry Ford never
said that we can't find any historical
evidence of it but it's sort of a snarky
statement
and we might have said but his point was
simply that you know users don't know
what they want they only know what
they've got and so when you ask them
about what they mean they give you
variations of the things that they
already know about and that's the first
part of the problem problem with this
need finding thing is you go out and
let's say you were I was at Apple for
seven years but long before they started
doing phones but I know some problems
people from the original phone team they
knew they were gonna do a phone that
wasn't with the need fighting was about
any timing is all about what kind of a
foam over the features be you know how
would they to be presented what would be
the sort of model and then in paradigm
so let's say mirror we were on a team
like that and they've done a bunch of
market research and and a bunch of
ethnography and you determined that
users have a specific set of needs that
needs to find their phone numbers easily
needs to be able to navigate to website
usually things like that so you build
this really high-resolution prototype
which most people call a beta the beta
prototype is objectively you and your
team knows you have met all the needs
that the users have talked about you
show it to your customer expecting the
Nabal of it and what they say is the
thing that all engineers and designers
hate they say oh yeah that's what I said
I wanted but now that I see that I
changed my mind you know what I really
want
and isn't that maddening right and this
is where the engineers go back to the
marketing people and say hey you didn't
expect this right because we showed it
to users and they had other needs that
weren't that you never told us about and
the marketing guy said well you know we
built exactly we told you to build
exactly what they want and so if they
didn't like it you must not have built
what they wanted but instead of getting
into that conversation it's just got to
acknowledge that humans are what it's
called technically a wicked problem
human beings do not stand still inside
some sort of market research bubble and
their needs and their wants are not
consistent from from moment to moment
and particularly when you've shown them
something that they never could have
imagined and here's the problem with
your problem looking probably as a
something that came out of social
science and I think
out of Berkeley we're studying urban
planning and why even though when you
build something everybody wants they
don't like it anymore they said oh we
could progress a crop that's difficult
or impossible to solve because of
incomplete contradictory and changing
requirements in addition to that these
requirements are often difficult to
recognize it's difficult to understand
if you really understood the
requirements of users because users are
so complex and here's that this is why
the data that you're looking for the
data that you want is about some future
state but that future state changes as
soon as you propose a solution so I want
a phone makes it easy for me phone
numbers you show me your phone with a
graphical user interface and then I say
well wow I had got blue user interface I
want a browser to and that was never in
the spec but you've shown me something
that changes my my perception of what's
possible because I only as a user I only
believe you know then you can get maybe
find a better way to do menus to solve
my problem of finding my phone numbers
in my address book but then later you
show me this other thing and I realized
so now if that's possible then all these
other things are possible and now I
change what I want and the users don't
often do this this notion that the
requirements are difficult to recognize
the users don't often recognize their
own needs what we call latent or
non-obvious needs because of what we
call the expert problem or what's what's
social scientists call the expert
problem when you give a person a piece
of technology but if you remember the
first time you use a spreadsheet the
first time you use a browser and and
maybe the user interface was clumsy or
difficult on the very first piece of
software you tried you knew it was
valuable to learn this so you worked
really hard to learn and you figured out
all these little tricks to be a member
Lotus 1-2-3 or the early days of Excel
it was hard to get how to do things so
you figured out all these little tricks
then you became the quote expert you
were the person in the office in an item
you use that piece of hard software and
so even though there were things in the
software that were difficult to use and
this applies to physical products right
and product but you know it's a little
bit a little bit of difficulty to
overcome and you become the expert
you've overcome the difficulty you know
the workarounds then when I ask you
what's you know what do you need is in
nothing and this works really well and I
have to observe how you're using it in
order to understand all the ways in
which you've worked around difficulties
that you're not obvious to you anymore
because you've become an expert Dave
Liddell who was one of the founders of
interval research here in Silicon Valley
talked about this problem in a couple of
papers he wrote he was also at the early
dark spark who worked on the star star
Michael computers just became the Apple
you know apples Macintosh interface he
talked about how software goes through
sort of three phases first only I can
only experts and gurus can use it this
was you know idea main things that in an
air-conditioned room and technicians in
like coats and then it becomes technical
software that's used by a large group of
people but the technical nature would
suffer requires developing expertise and
then the experts hoard that knowledge
and actually can't tell you that you
know about the workarounds that they've
they've invented finally software
becomes easily used in consumer software
so think of video games think of you
know Nintendo and things like that and
now all of the websites that you use
whose user interfaces are simple and
easy with a flick of a finger or a
thumbs you navigate through them and so
now you you're not expecting to have
expert knowledge just expecting to be
able to use the products because it's so
easy but we've entered the era of you
know expectations where everyone
believes that the product should be easy
to use and yet the design of products is
still mired in this old idea of trying
to capture the user requirements writing
a document and then executing on it when
in fact pedagogically you cannot
discover this the true nature of the
users needs
by simply interviewing and observing you
have to do the rest of the process which
is to provoke the users experience with
a prototype super low resolution if
possible
in order to you know kind of churn up
this next layer of information the thing
that when they say oh if that's possible
then you know what I what I really want
is and that's how you get to the
non-obvious user needs that's the most
important thing to understand I think
about these finding an empathy that it
works on this class of non-linear human
senses wicked problems so going back to
you know basic basics of them
understanding of how we know anything
I'm going to propose this kind of three
kinds of thinking engineering thinking
at bridge and the picture here is very
straightforward if I know the length of
the bridge the strength of the steel
beams I'm going to use and I know how
many cars with the load on that bridge
will be and what the loads from winds
and other things will be I have a
completely bounded set of information
and I have the equations that allow me
to solve for the strength of the bridge
the length of the bridge and its
structural elements and moreover if I
take that same set of specifications
same distance the same loads but I move
it from you know San Francisco to New
York the same bridge will work in both
cases because the boundary conditions of
the systems are exactly the same so we
stay with engineering thinking you can
solve your way forward because you have
a bounded system now in scientific
thinking it's a little different we have
a hypothesis and this is how we've moved
you know all knowledge forward they are
the hypothesis and then we create a
experiment which carefully isolates a
variable so that we can determine
whether it's independent or dependent on
other variables then we create a run the
experiment create a dataset and we
analyze the data and we either decide
the hypothesis true or false the two
things that are critical to this is that
we can show that we can design a good
experiment we can isolate the variable
we wish to test and that we keep our
hypothesis constant we can't change the
hypothesis to match the data that would
strung out of nescience of the journal
because that would be cheating the
hypothesis has to stand alone and so in
scientific thinking we analyzed our
report now we don't have all the data
inside right we're inventing new data
but we have this very rigorous process
of testing hypotheses through
experiments that allow us to validate
the true or false image of data and we
believe in Sciences first I don't have
Maserati it says as well then you get to
this other question problems we've just
been talking about where you have humans
in the equation and the data set is not
it's not confined it's not well bounded
humans come at problems from a variety
of different cultural social and
economic biases they look at products
based on products and services based on
the ones they've already experienced
they are very poor projecting forward
into technologies that they don't know
about or on possible solutions to the
problem that employ techniques that
they're unfamiliar with and and they
have this this problem changing you know
quality to them where once provoked with
a possible solution about something in
the future their needs change so they're
co-creating their needs with examples
that you show them only way we know to
solve that problem and the most powerful
way to solve that problem which is
actually you know we've been working on
for almost 50 years here we started this
we started giving the reason this and
our design part in Stanford in 1963 the
D schools just a little over ten years
old now he started in 2006 when that was
where we started teaching design
thinking to everybody but we've really
been working on our stuff for a long
time and what we've discovered through
many many iterations of the process is
it's the only way to discover the
non-obvious latent needs that nuanced
data set that is so valuable to
innovation is to build our way forward
to build and try the process over and
over again to eventually collapse the
users experience down to something that
they all agree is valuable at least for
that moment that picture up by the way a
teacher I have the eyes
a couple slides ago with the original
iPhone and it's kind of funny to look at
it now it looks so old fashioned and
only has a few icons on the screen it's
tiny it's got a little rounded just it's
interesting how not only do our gates
change but our sense of style and values
change and particularly in technology
products that evolve so quickly it's
funny to see something that's not even
ten years old look so so old-fashioned
I'm going to go through a build here of
what we call the five basic skills
around design thinking and this is you
know so we've discovered why customers
can't tell you what they need because
they actually don't know it and because
it evolves with with the experimentation
that you do with prototypes so now how
do we actually get there how does the
process that gets us what's innovation
data that we that we desperately you
know need if we want to have products
that are radically different than things
we've ever done before and open up new
value
you know propositions new markets and
and and or creative a non-profit world
you know new services that scaled very
rapidly so we say the five basic skill
sets that underlie this whole process
and you put them all together and you
use them in an iterative process and and
it turns out to be the only way we know
to invent and innovate regularly in the
future so the first that we talked about
observing with empathy and we call it
seeing the water you know this was this
was an old joke two fishes swimming
along a young fish swimming along and an
older fish swims by in the other
direction and as he goes by he says hey
boys how's the water and the other two
little fish swim on for a while and then
one turns Jamie says what the hell's
water and that's that's all joke but
it's all about you know we don't see the
environment we live in we don't
understand we don't pop them you make
make visible or make
actionable the culture we live in and so
this observing with empathy is about
seeing the water that your users us swim
in this expert problem where they don't
even notice the workarounds they're
doing anymore because they've gotten so
good at that piece of software or so
good at that interaction so you have to
break it down and you know see the water
which is all involved
with observation and this process of
provoking the world with prototypes you
glad you talk to people you show them
stuff you look at the world there and
you live with them to do a ride-along
for a day with a cop or you do a you
know in home visit with an elderly
person if your was another
aging-in-place project and you really
try to get you know into their shoes you
know we call it a moccasin walk you walk
up in their shoes and then but from that
you have all this data and I have to
develop insights because the idea after
empathy of define is creating a point of
view which is a little different than a
hypothesis because we're allowed to
change it as we get new data it's more
flexible than a hypothesis the insights
come from framing and reframing the data
and trying to understand what people
actually are thinking and feeling behind
their actions third skillset the ability
to to manage ideas and the flow of ideas
we talk about certain process being
divergent and actually when you form a
multidisciplinary team a radical
collaboration team you want to have some
people who in there so there's a couple
of tests for this but you kind of know
it and the people that you work with you
want to find some people with just
really good at divergent thinking in
other words they just really good at
having lots and lots of crazy ideas and
they then they don't and they're not
very good at figuring out which ones are
the good ones by the bad ones but they
they love the process of diverging and
opening up the solution space and anyone
can learn this if you learn to spring
from well you learn by mapping you learn
morphological analysis you learn some of
our improvisation techniques all of
which are just about diverging and
opening up the solution space but you
also want to be good at converging well
now we've got lots of good solutions to
choose from
what does our intuition tell us are the
best ones to choose to start narrowing
down
so this converging and diverging
thinking cognizant of when you do one or
the other is really one of the critical
things actually one of the hardest
things to teach is this the sort of
layer of insight that happens here
there's lots of different ideas we might
pursue but these ones over here feel
like they might be more interesting or
agender in a more generative direction
or might yield potentially some more
innovative solutions downstream the the
thing most teams do it they tried it
once they had lots of ideas they pick
something that they know how to do or
they pick something that's familiar to
them and that's typically the wrong
solution of the wrong solution set to
pick because they'll end up kind of back
where you started
so there's diverging and converging
process very important to manage and
this myth I love this deck we call it
irritant failure register failing a
whole bunch of different ways of
thinking about them David Kelly our
senior professor or the founder of the D
school the founder I do says you gotta
fail early if you want to succeed sooner
you know fail early fail fast to succeed
sooner they also talked about failing
forward and and this is the notion of
prototyping and very specifically
prototypes in this case are really low
resolution sort of attempts to
interrogate the customers and find out
more about their needs because you know
the needs will change once they see for
instance so it's not about projects
failing although to think if you're
going to if you're going to be in an
organization that wants to support
innovation you have to reframe even
project failure as learning and you have
to be willing to stay on a little bit
even at the project level if you want to
be an innovative organization but mostly
when we talk about failing fast to learn
something we're talking about
prototyping and building your what
building our way forward into the
environment but that we have things that
we can talk about and we can provoke
users and we can observe new behaviors
and it's never a failure if the user
uses the quota type in a way that was
unintended or doesn't use the prototype
at all but suggests an alternative path
that is a huge success even though you
might argue with the prototype fail so
you know after cycling through your
observation observation phase and your
frame phrase and figuring out you know
converging and diverging and then coming
down to a few steps of solutions such a
prototype you have to accept that you're
going to fail
forward and then as you begin to
recognize certain patterns our
persistence that users reacted the same
way positively to certain things and you
start building on those things and
making those things even more evidence
in your prototypes you get to the place
where you go from sort of interrogating
users to sort of selling them on your
idea this idea that David Kelley talks
about you know nowadays it's no longer
good enough for the design team to just
say here's our design what do you think
you have to take the design and put it
inside a story where it's the story of
the future the future of a user user
jock named John who wants to do
something new and different and here's
my product enabling John's life in a new
and different way if I tell the story of
John my product in the future making
John's life better I've created the
momentum around the design that will
drive it through even skeptical
organizations because now I have proof
of an example of a person using the
product in the future and storytelling
is become such an important part about
fun jazz I know that we have a whole
class on it so those you know I guess
five basic skills observing with empathy
developing insights and asking why the
ability to diverge and generate lots of
ideas and then converge and pick the
ones that are the most likely to lead to
innovation not the ones you're the most
comfortable with then moving through the
process by building a new way forward
building and failing building and
failing building and succeeding a little
building and finding a resonant point of
view where everybody is converging on
something that's new and interesting I
don't know the history of the case study
of tender the app but somebody figured
out that you know matching people
through profiles you know in a match to
match way was probably a good idea but
the real kind of innovation was this
gesture of you know swiping right
swiping left which is partly driven by
the technology in the interface of the
smartphone but it's also recognizing the
sort of casual nature of
of moving the data in and out of your
stream of consciousness in a way that
matched the way people were imagining
this in dating matching process going
and I think that deep resonance is what
comes you know tended to be the app that
everybody uses them and all the other
ones to fail checking all the friction
out of them interface is one thing but
adding in a little magical moment is
what we all look to do in design and
entender nailed it
okay so you've you've accepted users
can't tell you what they want
you've worked hard on your organization
have these five core you know skill
competencies and then you know you take
the data and you put in frameworks and
you guys seen these frameworks before
I'm just going to do three real quick
the you know the fundamental framework
is this notion of moving from the
country to the abstract and from here
into the future from from today on the
left side that little got lost and to
the future on the right side of the
horizontal axis so you can be in the
concrete here the abstract here the
abstract future or the concrete future
and you're basically moving around that
process and the frameworks that you're
Dalat deriving concrete here is your
observations from the field observations
notes videos interview transcripts you
move up into the abstract and you start
putting those frameworks into these
observations into some framework if the
first one we always talk about is the
empathy map the fact that people say and
do things in the world but what you're
really trying to get to is what they
think in field so you make a little 2x2
of this so you think feel and you
translate things from the same Duke
category to the thinking field category
using your own personal insight and
intuition knowing that you may be wrong
this is where your point of view is not
a hypothesis discussed well it's simply
a point of view it's a user put some
need plus sentence I think this is what
they were and they said this I think
this is what they were feeling let's go
try to see if that's true by building a
prototype that would work if that
thought were in fact accurate powerful
simple framework
the hierarchy of needs this is Maslow's
idea you know there's a lot of work now
that this isn't necessarily a hierarchy
anymore that people can have you know
not have all of their sights safety and
psychological needs met and yet still to
be working on self-actualization even in
the poorest communities even in South
Sudan in refugee camps where people
don't have security and maybe in food
and safety people still make jewelry
people still write in sing songs they
still perform artistic activities that
are sort of very human so although it's
not a hierarchy it's a good way of
necessarily looking at things if I've
made a if I've made observations in the
safety and psychology area but I have no
observations and the love belonging
esteem or self-actualization it gives me
a frame which would go back to the field
to ask different questions or I've found
you know three of the five things
already and I'm kind of try to intuit
the other two it gives me a framework
for what's missing and it drives the
design team to make better insights and
then finally this one that comes out of
a phonetics book on me finding Dave is
the founder of jump associates and also
has written a bunch on these planning is
another book called wired to care which
is a popular business book and he also
teaches at Stanford Ortiz John your
graduate in Pinal class
he's a great guy they developed what
they call the you know it's just it's
simple my mom and them on a e i o u
system for breaking down observations a
lot of times people come back in the
field and all these videos and stuff but
they don't really know what they mean
and this is a great way for kind of
looking at a video encoding certain
actions and then breaking those actions
down into insights or the actual
activities that you observed did the
team have a the people you were looking
at have a role to play where they just
participants how was the power of the
team divided up around activities what
did you notice environments but where
were they doing what they were doing
where they a public space a private
space was good space constrained or
okay were they able to move things
around or not interaction is where the
interaction with people are machines and
where the were the interactions with
people are machine what was the friction
in those interactions how did the
interactions occur what objects were
they interacting with because you know
doing thing about a 14-2 affordances how
how objects tell us what to do you know
hammers got a handle and a head and you
know exactly what you under no one ever
picks it up and ahead and tries to bang
with the handle there's a discretion the
hammer shapes the hand but it says this
this combination of hammer and hand that
is the tool and that's the object that
we can understand with digital objects
it's much more complex to understand
what were the things people were using
touching how are they working but if you
think about the simplicity of slide
swiping your son left and right you know
in a in an app for selection we start to
understand how critical objects and
interactions are and then other users
who else was there what were people
doing how are those people involved into
making the observable behavior easier or
harder to do and we find it so as I'm
just looking at the looking in a video
of a user doing something even just two
or three minutes of that video can take
several hours to decode what was going
on looking at you know activities
environments interactions objects and
users and then to take that and put it
into an empathy framework this is what
they were doing these are all the things
we observed from doing in all these
different modes and then those
translates to a mental model of what we
think they were what's happening in
their brain how are they imagining the
interaction to occur
why were they getting stuck at certain
homes and not others it's a really
simple but very powerful and breaking
down your observations and we really do
encourage video as a way of capturing
not only the simple and observable stuff
with body language emotional state when
someone's frowning when they're trying
to do something or smiling when they're
trying to do something tells you a lot
about what's the cognitive load that's
going on in their brain
so we get to the point and then we're
going to talk about you know how do you
make this stuff actionable and I've
alluded to it about you know 10 times
now you have to start with the
assumption that the information that you
can get is about the future is very
limited you don't live in the future so
you know is that not much you can do and
this is compounded by the expert problem
and by the problem of users changing
their needs so as you as you think about
this you let's say you come back with
lots of observations and lots of and
you've seen people using products and/or
services that are the things you're
interested in redesigning so you do have
a pretty strong data set giving very
nuanced set of data about what's going
on what's the cognitive model where are
the points of friction where is the
cognitive load and maybe higher than it
should be where are the points of
delight oftentimes if you want to do you
want to unseat an incumbent and they're
doing a great job of making something
easy lyft uber you know tinder our
snapchat these apps that make you know
instantaneous and ephemeral
communications super easy to do if you
want to if you want to unseat them join
out innovate then you're going to have
to be even more delightful it's not
simply enough to remove pain points or
to remove you know cognitive
discontinuities they're going to have to
out delight them you've got all this
information and then own and the only
way we know to make it actionable is
this process of prototyping and
iteration prototyping and iteration so I
don't have a specific example to show
you but in the case of going all the way
back to my example of alright I'm
working for a company that makes
wheelbarrows and we want to be the most
innovative company and let's say we want
to grow 10 times you know our size well
we're not going to you know fine you
know I guess we could start selling the
wheelbarrow we've got in new markets we
could go to China we could go to
that's a marketing solution that's not
and that may be an innovation but it's
not the same thing as a product
innovation so if we really wanted to say
how do you take a wheelbarrow company
and reframe it into a materials
logistics company or getting stuff moved
around where where you need it when you
need it come to them and we started
building simple prototypes like drone
delivery you can mock that up with a you
know a 100 dollar drone from the toy
store and you know paper bricks and we
could fly around job sites and see what
people thought about it we could we
could look at so the what's really is
going on it's an information systems
problem the stuff that we need is being
delivered to point to different places
than where we need it so could we design
an information system that solves that
problem should we design micro trucks
that could you know deliver stuff on
site and almost directly which is kind
of like what our forklift is only maybe
an autonomous forklift and that the
bricklayer could call from his
smartphone like he calls an uber so you
know you've got this how you create a
how might we statement was just based on
your insight that it's not about it's
not about wheelbarrows it's about
logistics how might we you know automate
the delivery of materials directly where
they're needed or how might we provide
an information system so that logistics
on a jobsite are you know that massively
improved or how might we create on-call
systems so that carpenters and
bricklayers
can summon materials where they want
when they want so each of those how
might we statements you know provokes a
whole series of possible prototypes
because you don't know if the ideas in
good idea but it's got an interesting
resonance it seems to match up some of
the data that you came back from the
field with and you take that and I know
it's a good how might we state and when
I can think of three prototypes I want
to build right away and the prototypes
are fast
they're inexpensive and low resolution
and I learned something
all right literally $100 drone and paper
bricks and I can understand what the
psychological and cultural light you
know advantages and disadvantages of
clients look around a job site is going
to be maybe people will think it's so
cool it'll be the neatest idea maybe
people think it's so dangerous and so
out of control that they would never do
it
or maybe carpenters and and bricklayers
are such conservative users that this
kind of technology intervention they
would consider way way way too abrupt I
often think about the introduction of
Google glass as an example of technology
actually pretty cool that was that was
introduced and handled so poorly that it
became an instantaneous disaster and
that was even amongst tech early
adopters so you make things actionable
by building in the world
thank you Bill so thank you so much for
this wonderful presentation it's always
interesting to hear about all the
different ways that we can learn and
engage with our customers and and arrive
at so many unexpected results so bill
one of the questions that often comes up
is around this question of failure and
risk-taking what is the role of
risk-taking in generating ideas how
important is that and how do people
overcome that you know fear of failure
yeah you know it's a great question it
comes up all the time when we do the
master class I've been pull people in
advance about you know what do you want
to what do you want to learn before you
get there and one of the things they
talk about is hey my organization
doesn't like big a lot of risks we're
very conservative organization failure
you know has a really high cost around
here and yet we still want to be a beta
and you know what I do and I do a lot of
Tours the d.school as well and I'm
talking to companies and they and I say
buddy the lair of course sales they say
we want to be more innovative and then
go great what do you want to you know
what are you willing to change and they
say nothing and I go well that's going
to be difficult the you know if you're
trying to invent something that's never
been done before if you're trying to
create a product or service or or
you know in an area like the wheelbarrow
company do something that has never been
done before they you know look at
venture capitalists who are supposed to
be really smart and invest in you know
ten companies done only nine of them
succeed seventy percent of new products
introduced in the United States and by
some measures you know failed to ever
you know return seventy cents in return
do not return the investment made in the
development of those products then over
the next two or three years so seventy
percent of products are failing me 90
percent of venture capitalists companies
are failing and yet the the ones that
succeed are so powerful the googles the
apples who sent checks living there so
powerful there must be something about
being comfortable with some level of of
failure now you know our idea is that
you fail really early in the process
because that's when you can do the most
learning but if you if you have an
organization that's not willing to take
risks at all then my only question is
you know if you know you I believe that
you don't actually have a choice that
innovation is going to happen in your
marketplace whether you're participating
or not so they are your only choice is
do I want to participate in innovation
and try to stay ahead of my competitors
or am I willing to you know sort of
state in a defensive posture and defend
my position continue to extend my
products you know incrementally but boy
if Google or somebody else comes around
and bully out innovates me I will be
caught you know flat-footed then and
probably see my markets and my margins
decline so you know when I these
companies come I said well you don't
really have a choice you neither do the
innovation or one of my students is two
o'clock and one of my 25 or 26 year old
students gonna go out and start a
startup in Silicon Valley you know
out-innovate you in your space and then
you're going to be you know get then
you're going to be faced with with the
declining market so the the correlation
between the ability to take and and take
and manage risk appropriately and
to actually reward appropriate kinds of
failures sailors are there learning
opportunities when we see companies
doing those things they tends to
innovate their competitors so it's just
something you're going to have to get
used to managing like you manage any
other risk in an organization and look
like 90 percent of your portfolio of
development activities will probably be
you know what we would call it Apple
line extension so simply the next the
next notebook the next iPad the next
phone but every once in a while you're
going to be called upon because the
market forces to come up with a
completely new completely you know not
in a straight line this is this is
something no one was predicting kind of
product and in order to do that you have
to be willing to fail remember the
iPhone team failed three times with
Steve Steve turned down their their
iPhone three times he said it wasn't
innovative enough it wasn't it wasn't
good enough and so you know they can do
that anybody can handle it this failing
in front of Steve is not was not a
pleasant experience yeah yeah and I
think I think it's important to remember
that the big companies can also fail we
in fact had a question from one of the
participants about you know if the
companies such as Google can fail with
Google glass you know what will what
will the rest of us smaller and less
successful people do and and I think
what you might be saying is that this
failure is part of the processing you
need to kind of learn to to live with it
and after and learn from it and benefit
from it is that correct
yeah absolutely and just a quick comment
on Google glass it's a classic example
of actually a very poorly managed
project and a very poorly executed thing
I don't think it represents you know a
great innovation on Google's cars at all
it's what it falls into the category of
we see lots of startups in Stanford and
you know I know some people come looking
for advice and and they come in and
they're so excited about their product
and they show it to you and you know
something's it's so hard it's so
technical it's so amazing we solve this
technical huge technical problem and
then first question is great who needs
it and what this for what what problems
is some is it no no you don't get it
it's the tech
Algie is so cool the problem with the
rule acids was all technology they
didn't understand they didn't take into
account to social and emotional issues
or wearing something on your face they
didn't take into account the privacy
issues of having an always-on camera
that didn't give any any signal to be to
the non participant that they were being
photographed and so it violated so many
social and and sort of privacy norms and
it occluded the face in a way that made
the person look foolish
and so it's like all of these things
were easily discoverable had they done
to me finding but it was a books we call
a technology push projects or they're
just pushing technology into the world
and hoping to find a quote market fit
that almost never works interesting
that's that's helpful are there any
specific traits or characteristics of
people that you look for that could be
more successful in performing Design
Thinking activities that satirize that
is there something that you recommend
looking for or kind of developing as a
preserve wanting to do more of that you
know it there is actually um and it's
interesting you know if you come to to
an undergraduate my program or graduate
student will teach you the entire
process remember future prototyping
through manufacturing production you
know business planning instant but of
course some people are really good at
one or two of the page something but
we're good at business planning
something but really good at
understanding markets and how to
distribute distribute things very subtly
but there's a class of people that are
just really good at the design research
part the empathy observation part they
can have very high social IQ so they're
social emotional you know intelligence
is very high they tend to be incredibly
good listeners because mostly this is
just about listening and observe it's
not so much about interviewing it's
interesting people who are great news
reporters a friend of mine teaches
journalism at the Emerson College in
Boston and he was a journalist for many
years for the Boston Globe he says good
journalists are just nosy people
they're not good listeners they just
want to pry into other people's lives
and find out what's going on and write
it up that's the opposite of an
empathetic listener so I've noticed some
of my students just have a natural
tendency towards listening they have a
natural tendency they have an open sort
of big area sness which invites people
to talk to them they're the kind of
folks that they were sitting on an
airplane would talk to everybody you
know in their section at some point but
they're not overbearing so the high
social emotional intelligence is sort of
a probably an extrovert or open mindset
tend to be the best at the design
research side now that's all learn about
for sure but some people just have it
naturally great so I think we have we
have just three more minutes we'll have
time for one more question before we
take that just a reminder to everybody
that we will be we are recording this
webinar and an email with the link to
the recording will be sent to all of you
so last question you described earlier
that it might take a few hours to kind
of get all the data and information from
even a few minutes of a video does that
could at least the over analysis of the
the day that you're collecting and how
do you avoid that well you know one of
them since I mentioned in the very I
think the first slide was a biased act
so although you do out in the field you
collect all this video and data and by
the way we do a bit so I mentioned does
everybody go on the team we typically go
in twos because someone can do the
interviewing while someone's taking
notes or running cameras very very
discretely because you like the person
talking this one has to be taking notes
but when you come back in three or four
teams of all types of different users
you need sometimes I collate that
information and just sort of chunk
really don't understand it
so as soon as you believe you have leave
even a cursory understanding or
beginning understanding of the users or
Mahina how nightly statement and build
the prototype because your your your
your data set is going to be incomplete
anything and you know that because as
soon as you build a prototype the users
will will will
you know I say kings are nice but what
that really will do is I'll just evoke
new responses
now that they know there are other
possibilities so the bias to action
would say you know spend seventy or
seventy percent of your time in the
field either interviewing are trying
prototypes and thirty percent of your
time on the analysis and we actually
measure our student teams on master
teams they have to tell me every week
how much time they spend doing and how
much time they spend talking and if I
don't see a 70/30 split I push them back
out into the field to do more more
fieldwork which can be building you know
the prototype building and testing is
part of the tenancy processes where the
part of the the process connects back
again to the front part okay I think
we're probably out of time
yeah thanks everybody for the singer and
everybody going and hung in there
through the whole time they really
appreciate it thank you everyone have a
good rest of your day thank you for
spending your morning with us